John wick chapter three Parabellum once
again stars Keanu Reeves as that title
character and Halle Berry this time
around as well Ian McShane tons of
amazing actors are in this film and this
is the continuation of what has become
Keanu Reeves most consistent franchise
this film picks up just about where the
last one ended John is on the run he is
about to be declared excommunicate oh
and every assassin in New York City is
going to be after him for a humungous
bounty so we followed John on various
adventures throughout the city at night
trying to escape death eventually
through other places as well where he
meets Halle Berry's character and some
other stuff happens and I won't get into
spoilers this is a great movie this is a
great action movie this is yet again
another extremely exciting entry in this
franchise if you had told me back in
2002 when they were shooting Matrix
Reloaded in Matrix Revolutions back to
back that the Matrix trilogy would
actually not be the most consistent
action trilogy that Keanu Reeves stars
in it would actually be later this is
the most consistent and entertaining
franchise in regards to action that
Keanu Reeves has ever started and one of
the best today I don't think it's quite
as good as the mission impossible
franchise but in regards to consistency
they are knocking it out of the park
this film has the most action sequences
out of the three possibly the most
intense not quite reaching the heights
of the glorious Club sequence in the
first film
mostly because that sequence was also
boosted by a lot of drama with this
revenge plot but in regards to intensity
and consistency the action is almost
wall-to-wall in this movie and that does
create a danger because you can get
oversaturated with action you can have
too much of it to the point where it
becomes monotonous in the case of this
film they do enough with different
weapons and different modes of
transportation horses for instance and
they change so much where it does feel
like you're seeing a new type of action
throughout every scene the one thing
I'll complain about in regards to the
action is there's there's way too many
throws and some of this is more
noticeable because the action is filmed
almost entirely in wides for very long
takes which is wonderful and makes me
very happy
but since they don't do as much cutting
which again I love you can notice
there's a lot of throws and sometimes
you can see that there are parts where
actors could have gotten a hit in if
they wanted to but you can see they're
sort of waiting for that hit because
they've choreographed this but I'm
almost okay with noticing those little
flaws since I get a lot of really great
wide shots instead of having you know
quick cuts all throughout because
obviously that's just disgusting and
nobody wants to see that in an action
movie the John wick franchise has proven
time and time again that long takes with
real stunts and actors who can do those
stunts and a lead star like Reeves who's
willing to get down and dirty and get in
the dirt and really really get sweaty
and disgusting and bloody and gross with
these action scenes that's why these
movies work so well because they're
built around these amazing sequences the
story is not as important for these
movies it's more about set piece set
piece set piece and normally that would
suck
and I would say that's a terrible thing
that you're doing with this movie that
you're more concerned about that than
the story but in the case of the John
wick films it's almost what they're
about similar to the mission impossible
franchise it's about making your jaw
drop every five to ten minutes and
making you sort of want to giggle with
excitement every time this insanely
violent and gory thing happens in front
of you big surprise for me in this movie
was Halle Berry she is just as good as
Keanu Reeves in her action scenes she
clearly has been trained immensely just
as Reeves and the other stunt team has
and what they did incorporating dogs in
this scene that she's in I thought it
was amazing one of my favorite action
scenes in the franchise she really
really did a great job in this movie
she's not in the film as much as you
might have thought based off the
trailers but she definitely gets a lot
of moments that are really
badass that just made me extremely
excited as an action junkie and it was
also a little bit cathartic to because
she's an action star that has had a lot
of opportunities and none of them have
really worked out that well for her as
jinkx and die another day she was
basically eye candy she didn't really
get to do that much and Catwoman we all
know how that turned out so it was
really great to see her in an action
role
just blowing it out of the water and
doing such a phenomenal job there is
however a little downtime in the middle
of this film that felt boring while I
was watching it and after a certain
choice is made by John wick it feels
almost entirely unnecessary he has to go
through this walk through the desert
we've seen little hints at this in the
trailers and it leads to a tough choice
that he has to make and it feels like he
has a newfound resolve not some 10 to 15
minutes later he reverts back on this
choice and it makes you feel like you
don't quite understand the motivation
for John wick in this movie in fact for
a large portion of the movie it's a
little unclear what his motivation is
once you learn what his motivation is in
that desert sequence again I'm not
spoiling anything you're like okay I see
what you're trying to do but then after
like one conversation he turns his back
to that motivation and I'm totally okay
with that choice it makes for the better
and more entertaining third act for sure
it's just that there wasn't enough time
allotted to that development to make it
realistic that he would suddenly turn
his back on this really intense decision
he makes and all of this
life-threatening stuff he goes through
to make said decision and then like 10
minutes later being like it never
mind and my last issue with the movie is
sort of a holdover from the last film
this is a spoiler for the ending of John
wick too so if you haven't seen John
wick - that's your warning at the end of
that film you find out that there are
assassins throughout all of New York and
these killers are just everywhere and it
kind of strained credibility when he's
running away and you see like all these
people noticing him and all of the
people who stopped walking in the park -
and so when it came to this film there
were a lot of sequences where where
folks are killed in public and you're
expecting screams and people fleeing and
you don't see that and I'm like alright
I can't buy that everyone in this room
as an assassin I just don't buy that and
so still that was a holdover from the
last film where I just didn't buy that
there were that many people in New York
under control of this organization it's
a more entertaining and more fast-paced
film than the sec
film which I liked but still I would say
the first film has the most dramatic
heft has the most investing story the
third film at times story wise does show
some signs of wear but the incredible
action sequences and the stunt team
encounter ease and Halle Berry and all
these actors who are just giving their
all to these sequences you have to hand
it off to them this is such a great
action achievement and it makes someone
like me extremely excited about what
else could possibly come in this
franchise if they decide to make more
I'm gonna give John with chapter 3 a B+
so guys let me know what you thought of
John wick 3 when you get a chance to see
it I also want to give a big thank you
to the sponsor for this video and that
is Skillshare Skillshare is an amazing
online community filled with classes
video tutorials things on design
business editing cinematography drawing
arts they have over 25,000 classes
available online to learn in just about
anything that you have an interest in
and it's extremely simple too because
you can do it from home there are so
many classes especially related to film
like with creative writing some of the
ones I specifically liked were the
writers toolkits six steps to a
successful writing habit and creative
writing essentials writing standout
opening scenes I mentioned this in my
most recent filmmaking journey video but
opening scenes are incredibly important
it's one of the things I loved about
John wick 3 like the first 20 minutes of
this movie which obviously is more than
just one opening scene is almost
non-stop because you're you're right
after the second film and it builds so
much momentum in that opening and it's
so important to learn about how to
really grab your viewers or your readers
in that opening moment Skillshare is
also super affordable at less than $10 a
month but the best part is that if you
use this link that's in the description
below
the first 500 of you can get two months
for free so please do visit this link in
the description and check out Skillshare
and get two months for free I really do
think it's a great service thank you so
much of them for sponsoring this video
and thank you to you guys for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]